[Music]
hi attend the patient's perception of
the disease become part of the medical
treatment in Denmark this approach is
already a reality
to understand how it works though let's
take a step back
[Applause]
Hana is a 57 year old Danish pensioner
she stopped working due to a severe
intestinal disease and has had to
undergo regular checkups ever since
thanks to the patient reported outcome
questionnaire she can inform the
hospital about any developments with her
disease thus improving her knowledge
regarding her own health and improving
the efficiency of the next consultation
it's very useful because when I go to
the doctor I often forget to tell her
some details
but here you have to fill in a
questionnaire before the consultation so
you have the time to think about
everything and the doctor will have
answers to the questions that can come
up during each visit some some hits
skill come up there again
closer look at the pro or patient
reported outcomes this online
questionnaire was introduced into the
Danish Healthcare System first for
neurology and later extended to other
medical fields
questions on specific symptoms quality
of life and daily activities the
initiative allows for greater
involvement from the patients and
improves their knowledge on their
condition while health professionals
gain first-hand information to help them
refine their treatment approach
[Music]
at the University Hospital of arhus
Denmark this online service is mainly
used for cases of chronic diseases which
generally require regular checkups
[Music]
patient reported outcomes Pro is a
brilliant way of getting an insight into
a patient's symptoms prior to seeing
them in the Outpatient Clinic we already
have a lot of answers and we then know
what we should focus on whether there
are any symptoms related to The Chronic
bowel disease where we need to alter the
medical treatment this approach which
relies heavily on the collection and
sharing of medical information is an
example to follow for the future
European health data space which will
give a cross-border dimension to this
type of method another feature of the
Danish initiative is that artificial
intelligence is used to perform an
initial screening of information
the question is are processed with an
algorithm to show that if the patient is
fine and we do not need to talk with the
patient or see the patient some comes
out as we call it yellow to say if it's
necessary to make a telephone call for
the patient the other comes out red to
say it is necessary to see the patient
Pro is a useful tool for regularly
monitoring patients with chronic
diseases and allows doctors to be more
reactive even before the scheduled
consultation it's also help us to find
out who are the relevant patients to see
in this way when we process it with we
end up spending our time on the ill
patients and not on the patients who are
actually in a well-being situation with
a Chronicle disease
at a time when the sharing of medical
information is a critical issue for our
Health Care Systems patients have more
say than ever in helping the medical
industry create products and services
that are tailored to their experience
[Music]